.
AND ALSO SUPPORTS THE INSANE
DEFUND THE POLICE MOVEMENT.
HERE WITH MORE ON THAT IS HER
REPUBLICAN OPPONENT, WHO IS
MAKING GREAT STRIDES, HAS SHOWN
UP WITH A SLIGHT LEAD IN THE
POLLS RECENTLY, ADAM LAXALT IS
WITH US.
THIS IS A WINNABLE RACE, IT
WOULD BE A PICKUP FOR
REPUBLICANS.
YOU ARE NOW IN THE LEAD BUT IT'S
STILL VERY CLOSE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT FIRST THE
BOARDERS, WHICH NEVADA HAS TO
DEAL WITH ON A PRETTY HIGH
LEVEL.
>> YEAH, LOOK, MY OPPONENT HAS
SAID THAT THIS IS MISINFORMATION
AND THE BORDER IS NOT OPEN.
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE DEALING WITH
IN THESE HUGE SENATE RACES WHERE
THESE DEMOCRATS HAVE UNLIMITED
MONEY AND THEY GET TO ABSOLUTELY
DISTORT THEIR RECORD TO OUR
VOTERS, AND THEY JUST DO IT
NONSTOP.
IF SHE WOULD STAND UP TO JOE
BIDEN, THEN WE COULD ACTUALLY
GET A SECURE BORDER.
SHE HAS THAT MUCH POWER IN THIS
SWING STATE.
BUT INSTEAD SHE CONTINUES TO
STAND WITH HIM AND TO SEE THE
LEFT LOSE THEIR MIND OVER THE
MARTHA'S VINEYARD PLANES.
I WENT TO THE BORDER, AND THE
PEOPLE ARE DYING ON THE BORDER
NOW.
THAT'S THE HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
OF THE TRIP.
AND FOR THEM TO ACT LIKE THEY'RE
GOING TO TRY TO GO AFTER HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CHARGES FOR GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS WHEN HUMAN TRAFFICKING,
BY THESE CARTELS, IS AN ALL-TIME
HIGH?
PEOPLE LIKE KATHERINE CORTEZ
MASTO ARE NOT STANDING UP FOR
WOMEN THAT ARE BEING HUMAN
TRAFFICKED INSTEAD THEY'RE LYING
ON COMMERCIALS, SEAN.
WE CERTAINLY NEED HELP IN MY
RACE, AT ADAM LAXALT.COM I CAN
TELL YOU THAT BUT WE FEEL
STRONGLY ABOUT THE RACE THAT
PEOPLE WILL SEE THROUGH THESE
LIES AND THEY UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS RACE WILL DECIDE WHO HAS
CONTROL OVER THE SENATE.
>> Sean: I THINK YOU HAVE A
CRITICAL RACE AND IT'S A PICKUP
AS I SAID FOR REPUBLICANS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT CORTEZ MASTO
AND HER SUPPORT FOR THIS FCC
NOMINEE WHO HAS SHOWN NOTHING
BUT DISDAIN AND HOSTILITY
TOWARDS CONSERVATIVES AND THEIR
OPINIONS.
MAYBE EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY,
SOMEBODY THAT'S BEEN VERY
ANTI-POLICE, RADICAL IN HER
OPINIONS, AND YOU HAVE PUT OUT A
STATEMENT THAT SHE MUST OPPOSE
BIDEN'S ANTI-POLICE FCC NOMINEE.
HAVE WE GOTTEN ANY RESPONSE YET?
>> WELL, OF COURSE NOT.
AND THE MEDIA STILL HASN'T ASKED
HER THE QUESTION.
BUT HERE'S THE KEY.
SHE IS HANGING ON BY A THREAD,
THIS NOMINEE.
IF KATHERINE CORTEZ MASTO
ACTUALLY DID WHAT SHE CLAIMS TO
VOTERS AND STOOD AGAINST HER
PRESIDENT AND SAID THIS NOMINEE
IS TOO EXTREME FOR THIS
APPOINTMENT, SHE COULD ACTUALLY
GET THIS NOMINEE KNOCKED OUT.
THE PATERNAL ORDER OF POLICE
HAVE SAID THIS IS THE MOST
ANTI-POLICE NOMINEE IN THE BIDEN
ERA, AND MASTO PRE TENDS LIKE
SHE SUPPORTS COPS.
OF COURSE THE PATERNAL ORDER OF
POLICE ARE STANDING WITH ME AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN MY STATE
BECAUSE THEY KNOW I'LL BE WITH
THEM WHEN THEY ACTUALLY NEED ME
SHE'LL BE THERE WITH RHETORIC.
IT IS IMPORTANT THIS APPOINTY,
NOMINEE WITH THE MASSIVE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT WITH THE
BORDER, SHE IS THE DECIDING VOTE
THAT COULD HAVE GONE AGAINST
BIDEN AND ACTUALLY STARTED
SAVING OUR COUNTRY.
>> Sean: WELL, WE'RE GOING TO
FOLLOW YOUR RACE, THIS WOULD BE
AN IMPORTANT PICKUP FOR
REPUBLICANS.
ONLY